you know there is so much to unpack from
alec baldwin's prime time sit down so
let's break down alex account of the
tragedy that transpired on the set of
rust
the trigger wasn't pulled i didn't pull
the trigger
well who did one should navigate this by
saying as little as possible no firearm
can be discharged without pressing the
trigger
analyzing alex trigger denial for e.t
weapons expert steve wolf and pr expert
joe koncha steve holding a cult 45 the
same type of gun alec used demonstrated
his theory that if alex finger was
already resting on the trigger he
wouldn't have to pull it for the gun to
fire
it has a hammer
which you pull back it has a trigger if
you put your finger on the trigger
before you [ __ ] the gun
and then you [ __ ] the gun and release
the hammer the hammer will fall and
discharge the gun without a second
pressing of the trigger
where did that bullet come from somebody
brought live rounds plural
onto the scent of the film
so how could alex's emotional exclusive
interview with abc news's george
stephanopoulos affect the investigation
he's a producer on the film and is named
in two lawsuits it can come back to bite
him because his own words could be
entered into the court record all it
takes is one screw-up and that could
screw up the entire case
there are some who say you're never
supposed to point a gun
at anyone on a set no matter what
unless the person is the cinematographer
who's directing me where to point the
gun for her camera angle
even if a gun were to miraculously go
off this would not absolve pointing a
gun at a person
do you feel guilt
no
no i might have killed myself if i
thought i was responsible
i don't say that lightly many celebs are
supporting alec after the actor posted
this tribute to wife ellaria quote no
matter what happens to me if i win or
lose anything you have given me a reason
to live our life with our family is all
i care about
i couldn't get my career anymore is it
over but why well it could be
this tragedy defines alec baldwin and
when you watch him on screen it's going
to be hard to separate what happened
here with this shooting and alec baldwin
the person and the actor
[Music]